former President Bill Clinton is keeping
silent this morning after Monica
Lewinsky revealed new details about
their affair in an AME Series I blurted
out you know I have a crush on you and
he laughed and smiled and then asked me
if I wanted to go into the back office
well the series called the Clinton
affair premiered last night Tony Tecopa
is here with a look at how the public
perception of Lewinsky has changed in
recent years Tony good morning I didn't
get to see it so I'm interested yeah
it's interesting and how it's changed
how it will change in the future I mean
Monica Lewinsky has felt that over the
years she's been defined by others as a
political problem or a late-night
punchline but now and perhaps her most
extensive interview to date she seems to
be taking on a new role as the author of
her own story he you know paid a lot of
attention to me
Monica Lewinsky says she still feels
ashamed at how she behaved after meeting
President Clinton as an intern at the
White House in 1995 my underwear head
showing my thong underwear and I thought
well I'll up the game it was
unnoticeable to everybody else in the
room but he noticed once the affair
began Lewinsky says parts of the
relationship moved out of her control if
he called me I couldn't call him back I
was completely at his mercy in that way
three years later the affair made
national headlines I did not have sexual
relations with that woman
Bill Clinton eventually regained his
footing on the public stage there's a
lot of votes still in play here Lewinsky
meanwhile reveals she considered suicide
it just
I was mortified and afraid of what this
was gonna do to my family what she's
doing now is just taking back her own
identity he Lauren a nose is an attorney
and columnist who's written about
Lewinsky for the website law and crime
while President Clinton has largely
avoided discussing the affair you didn't
apologize to her I have not talked to
her Nana says the public perception of
Lewinsky is changing in the me2 era
Monica Lewinsky has recast herself as
someone who was done harm by Clinton by
his presidency by the press by the
public so to some degree she has flipped
that script but Bill Clinton is still a
very powerful man and as a result she
still does not have the full ability to
rid herself of everything that went into
vilifying her for decades but something
Lewinsky hopes she can change is how we
talk about her episode with President
Clinton it's not the Lewinsky scandal in
her view but the Clinton affair bye-bye
Lewinsky scandal she wrote recently 20
years is long enough for that mantle I
think it's good you know a lot of people
feel that it's good she gets to tell the
story on her own terms
but I am wondering her endgame here is
she hoping that the perception of her
will change whatever your perception was
of her she hoping that it will change
she's hoping that by talking about it
she can find a better way forward for
herself but also act as a kind of
warning for other people when they walk
down somewhere path it's interesting you
have a new generation of people that are
just learning about this right angle
people that covered in the past looking
at it come through a different scope now
it makes me look at it a different way
yeah Tony thank you yes thank you